meanwhile as they impoverish you
and as they tell you that we are going
to have to lower our economic estimates
because of climate justice and
environmental justice and white
supremacy and all the rest of the silly
progressive buzzwords
as they tell you that the best you can
hope for is to one day work at a wind
turbine factory with a government
unionized job
as they do that
they are given lottery tickets to uh
illegal immigrant families that's
exciting stuff according to the wall
street journal
the united states is currently in talks
to pay hundreds of millions of dollars
to families separated at the border
okay again this is kind of incredible
and so so americans are experiencing
wild out of control inflation
they're 10 million open jobs and people
aren't getting back in the workforce
they have supply chain bottlenecks joe
biden is pledging to basically lower his
economic growth estimates to below two
percent a year for the rest of time
but we have enough money in the bank to
be paying i kid you not 450 000
per person in compensation to immigrant
families separated by the trump
administration
there are several agencies working to
resolve lawsuits filed on behalf of
parents and children who say the
government subjected them to lasting
psychological trauma the us departments
of justice homeland security and health
and human services are considering
payments that could amount to close to
one million dollars a family
though the final numbers could shift
people familiar with the matter said
most of the families that crossed the
border illegally from mexico to seek
asylum in the united states included one
parent and one child the person said
many families would likely get smaller
payments depending on their
circumstances the aclu has identified
about 5 500 kids separated at the border
over the course of the trump
administration citing figures provided
to it by the government
the number of families eligible under
the potential settlement is expected to
be smaller about 940 claims have so far
been filed by the families the potential
payout could be a billion bucks or more
so remember there is a zero tolerance
enforcement policy in which the united
states would not just release illegal
immigrants into the interior of the
united states after giving them a piece
of paper saying come back in a month
the trump administration said we're not
doing that if you come you will be held
until you actually have your asylum date
until we find out whether you are here
or whether whether you're here for good
reason or whether you're just trying to
cross the border illegally now there was
something called the flora settlement
the florida settlement said that kids
could not be held with their parents in
confinement so instead kids were
separated from parents very often they
were handing handed to a relative
sometimes they'd be put in a holding
facility for a little while right but
that was because of the flora settlement
it was defined by law the two choices
were release the entire family unit into
the interior or two don't and you have
to separate the kids from the parents by
law because of the stupid flora
settlement
so that's what the trump administration
did now if you were one of the illegal
immigrants who came with your kid and
your kid was separated from you the
government is going to sign you a 450
000 check per person
so for your kid and for you
so not only did you get to enter the
united states illegally
you also get a giant check from the us
government signed by the taxpayer
is that exciting stuff from the biden
administration
the lawsuits allege some of the children
suffered from a range of ailments
including heat exhaustion and
malnutrition were kept in freezing cold
rooms and provided little medical
attention
that is indeed terrible you know what
else is a really bad idea paying people
for the separation of the family
required by law when they cross the
border you want to incentivize illegal
immigration don't just say come on over
here and we got a bunch of free welfare
benefits and we're not going to kick you
out say if we happen to separate you
because we have to by law we will sign
you a million dollar check
that's crazy towns
in recent months lawyers for the
families and government have told courts
overseeing the cases they are engaged in
settlement negotiations
league alert deputy director of the aclu
says quote president biden has agreed
that the family separation policy is a
historic moral stain on our nation that
must be fully remedied
that remedy must include not only
meaningful monetary compensation but a
pathway to remain in the country
so again remember that they are not only
pushing for a giant check they're also
pushing for people who just get to stay
here
in his first weeks in office biden
pledged to reunite the separated
families by the way not all the families
have been reunited even still
senator tom cotton said the biden
administration's promises of citizenship
and entitlement programs have already
caused the worst border crisis in
history a huge cash reward will make it
even worse
some government lawyers view the payouts
as excessive for people who had violated
the law by crossing the border
one government lawyer threatened to
remove his name from the case out of
disagreement with the potential
settlement offer
in another instance a department of
homeland security attorney involved in
the settlement talks complained on a
conference call the payouts could amount
to more than some families of 9 11
victims received
so
if that's the case i mean think about
the insane moral logic of that you cross
the border illegally with your kid
because you're attempting to get into
the country illegally you're separated
the government says here's a million
dollar check and you get to stay in the
country
now you're a family member of somebody
who
got vaporized on 911 by a terror attack
on the world trade center you get a
lower check
than the illegal immigrant who just
crossed the border for pain and
suffering
that's unbelievable
trying to take the case's trial would be
unpredictable with juries potentially
awarding larger sums to the family said
legal experts damaged class actions in
this kind of case are pretty rare it's
hard to think of a recent comparison
said margo schlanger who ran the civil
rights office during the obama
administration
it's a complicated complex piece of
litigation to try to resolve hundreds of
different lawsuits at the same time
sometimes even more complex to try the
cases
many of the families filed tort claims a
type of civil claim seeking damages for
loss or harm some of the cases were
resolved under the trump administration
in a 2019 settlement in new jersey for
example an adult in a minor received a
total of 125 thousand dollars
many of those cases were still pending
at the start of the biden administration
but again the fact that this
administration is now considering a
widespread policy of just giving money
to people for this sort of thing like
pretty insane making illegal immigrant
families rich making american families
poor that is a hell of an energy and
making everybody dependent illegal
non-illegal everybody depending on the
federal government
you wonder why the economic boom is
stalling out you wonder why a feeling of
innervation has settled across the
american population when it comes to
work this would be the reason
you have an entire side of the political
aisle in the united states that
basically now says that work is
unnecessary you shouldn't aspire to
anything the government will take care
of you cradle to grave if you don't want
to vote for that then vote for glenn
young and if you're in virginia and if
you don't like it don't vote for
democrats across the country in 2022. i
still think that most americans have
aspirations to live more than the life
of linda
if that's the case
then democrats have a real cruising
coming to them the democrats have a real
bruising coming to them in 2022.
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment